all right
good morning
well it is great to see you all here
this morning
this is a historic and fun moment
and it gives me enormous pleasure to
welcome you
on this occasion let me first extend a
special warm welcome to the Wasserman
family who are with us today Stephen
Gabrielle Sophie Dan Christine and Diana
future
and I just want to mention some of our
speakers Sam Chauncey Eve heart rice
Vera Wells and of course our artist
Brenda zomani uh this of course is made
all the more meaningful because you are
here uh yells Yale College's first
classes of women the classes of 1971
1972 And 1973. thank you for joining us
this morning some of you are here in the
Morse Recital Hall of Sprague Hall some
of you are online but we welcome all of
you to this occasion I'm thrilled that
you are with us I'm thrilled so many
alumni are here this weekend
so when women first began their studies
in Yale College I don't think people
fully understood
how essential
co-education was to Yale's future
but I do think algo Wasserman understood
and I think she was enormously
persuasive as a result in 1969 the
president of the University Kingman
Brewster asked Elgin
to implement much of the transition for
the first classes of women in Yale
College including admissions issues
housing
academic programming
co-education was clearly on the horizon
when she began thinking about this
but it was hardly assured
and we have Elga to thank for everything
that went right and believe me I know
not everything went right
but elga's story is uh doubly remarkable
because of its improbability Elga
arrived in this country in 1936 she was
a 12 year old German Jewish refugee
and then she would go on to exemplify so
many ways in which women as students as
alumni as faculty as administrators
have contributed to Yale
but as well to our country more broadly
over the years
elga's uncommon Brilliance her work at
Yale her work at other institutions led
to advances across multiple fields The
Sciences education law publishing
so the portrait which we're about to
reveal it really there really is
something behind
is an expression of enormous gratitude
by this institution
enormous gratitude that she brought her
exceptional gifts and her passion to
bear
Anya for the betterment of our community
so this portrait will hang at the bass
Library which is the central
undergraduate educational Hub on this
campus Central to academic life at Yale
it will remind future generations of
students of elgas and indelible imprint
on Yale
it's an imprint that has enriched this
institution incalcably
and it will challenge us and I I
actually
ask all of us
to recognize elgar's role in championing
equity and diversity at Yale and
throughout higher education
she was one of the first
but I know we're all committed to it
in all the ways in which those
challenges face us today
the exceptional inclusive community that
you see at Yale just walk through the
tent of those five-year reunion students
and you can you can feel it they're here
this weekend that exceptional inclusive
community that we see today at Yale
it's really a defining element of elga's
Legacy here
because of her Visionary leadership we
look with optimism to Future Generations
who will like the extraordinary first
women of Yale College many of you here
today are listening in
um okay that you all carry forward the
El's mission of light and Truth into the
world and so will they so thank you all
very much for being here I am delighted
to introduce our first Speaker Sam
Chauncey with whom Elga collaborated
closely to admit those first classes of
women
Sam is a member of the Yale College
Class of 1957 and then went on to serve
with great distinction in the Yale
Administration for more than two decades
he was an assistant dean of Yale College
a Special Assistant to president
Brewster Secretary of the university and
continues to be a trusted advisor to so
many of us please join me in welcoming
Sam Johnson
[Applause]
[Music]
I want to join president Sullivan in
welcoming the Wasserman family it's
wonderful to see all of you
I also see a lot of familiar faces
which is no surprise because I think
Elga and I interviewed every one of you
and of course the people we rejected are
not here so I'm I consider myself safe
algo Wasserman was a dear friend
and Elga was a visionary
my definition of a visionary
is a person with the energy of a
missionary
and the vision of a leader
Elga and her husband Harry were graduate
students together at Harvard
and Harry once told me that Elga was
indeed the better student
he became a respected and beloved
tenured professor
and she was relegated to the role of
research associate
happily
she was made an associate dean of The
Graduate School
and her administrative skills her
determination and her wisdom became
known to others at Yale
when President Brewster put her in
charge of implementing co-education her
missionary energy was fired up
and she applied it to a vision that
she'd had long before she took this job
she wanted all of Yale
to become a place where women would have
the same chances
the same opportunities and the same
award rewards that men had
to achieve that she knew there were two
objectives
the first is numbers
women and men should be roughly even
in the student body The Faculty the
administration
and second the environment
men and women would work study teach and
administer in an environment that was
evenly hospitable to all
she knew she had to start with the
undergraduate effort but she never lost
sight of the greater goals
it's well known that there was tension
between Elga and Kingman Brewster
Kingman was immersed in the immediate
practical battles of the late 1960s and
early 1970s
and keeping an eye on the distant future
was not always easy
while Elga was laser focused on the long
run
Kingman often said to me that when we
when we were talking about the radicals
of that era that we should respect The
Passion of the radical for as he said I
quote today's wild idea may be
tomorrow's gospel unquote
I think he forgot that Elga was indeed a
radical
in the end I believe both Kingman and
elget did what they thought was best for
Yale
and worked hard at it
now more than a half a century later
we can see that much has been
accomplished
Yale College is roughly the same number
of women and men
and we are improving the areas in the
women with women faculty and Senior
Administration
but one of the environment
is the environment of yale1 which
heartily welcomes women as it always has
men
Elgin and I spent hours talking about
this
it's easy to see what you've achieved in
the numbers
but measuring the environment is much
more difficult
in those early days for example it was
the group's tangential degale Maurice
the Yale Club of New York the senior
societies
which at first made it clear that women
were not welcome
some had to be taken to court some had
to be pressured
indeed I pressured my own senior Society
so hard they expelled me
in addition there were hostile people
I remember a reference librarian who
openly said to everyone I will not help
one of those women
and we had to move her
changing the environment of an
institution is far more difficult than
changing the numbers
because Elga had educated me so well on
this subject I continued to think about
it today
I think we still have work to do
and as president salave has so often
reminded us we must be aware and
sensitive to how Yale the Yale
environments welcomes those once
excluded
I would I will welcome each chance to
see the wonderful portrait we're going
to unveil today
not only because Elga was such a good
friend and mentor
but also because I want to be reminded
every day
to renew what little personal efforts I
can contribute to the evening of the
numbers and the improving of the
environment so Yale welcomes everyone in
the same way
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
I
[Applause]
[Music]
and I want you to meet Diana Wasserman
good morning
I have to
see if I can get this at a level that
thank you Sam
thank you president salloway
Brenda islaminey did I say it right
pretty good yeah fellow speakers
and everyone at Yale who's been involved
in making this a reality
and thank you to my family for letting
me
be our spokeswoman
a special heartfelt thank you to all the
first women
who asked for this Memorial
both those in the room with us today
those on the live stream who couldn't be
in New Haven this weekend
and those
um
who are not but may
look in at the recording later
when you gathered four years ago to
commemorate 50 years of co-education at
Yale
I found it a truly transformative
weekend
my brothers and I traveled to the
infamous moris
to accept the Maurice Cup in our
mother's name
we reminisced about the stories she told
about her trials attending meetings at a
spot that had traditionally excluded
women
it was later in the weekend though
as I sat amongst you
that I came to realize just how very
much my mom meant to the hundreds of
first women who had gathered that fall
my glimpses of the portrait we are about
to see unveiled
show a woman in her 40s
she is the mother I knew as a teenager
like the members of the 50th Anniversary
class
in the spring of 1969 I too was a high
school senior about to head off to
college
I was pushing my mother away at a time
she was becoming a mentor
to so many of you
it took time for our bond to be
re-established
and for me to appreciate
what a truly remarkable woman she was
my mother died nine years ago
a few a few days before she passed
as I sat with her
through her period of hospice care
she told me how bad she felt and how
guilty that she was leaving me a country
in such a state in such crisis
talked then
about the cumulative challenges faced by
each new generation in history
I reminded her that when she came into
the world in Berlin in 1924 things
weren't exactly great for her
her family or for the world
the years have slipped by so fast
when I return to this city where I grew
up
I see amongst you Playmates from
childhood
classmates from high school
from college
for medical school
thinkers
fellow activists and now fellow retirees
going forward
it will be our daughters
our sons
granddaughters and grandsons
nieces
and nephews
and their children and grandchildren who
will carry the Torches of change
I am so glad the university is honoring
our mother with this affecting work of
art
by doing so
Yale is ensuring that her memory
her Legacy
may continue to be an inspiration
to all the forward-thinking students of
the future
thank you
[Applause]
let me welcome Anne Rice another member
of the Class of 73
to share her thoughts
good morning everyone
so first a few words of thanks to the
Wasserman family for sharing this moment
of Celebration with the classes of 1973
1971 as well as others
and to the university for recognizing
our deep admiration for Elga and
profound sense of gratitude and
commissioning this portrait
I'll begin with an imagined scene
set in November 1968.
picture if you will Elga sitting in her
office picking up the phone to hear
Kingman Brewster say I have a little
project for you and a terrific new title
I've decided to give you and Sam
Chauncey
just nine months to admit Yale's first
ever cohort of undergraduate women from
a deluge of applications
shoehorn the 588 women into Yale's
already stretched facilities address
their academic needs with only two women
professors on the faculty
find a way to mitigate the eight to one
male to female ratio and for good
measure create a sense of belonging
I have great faith in you
I know you can do this
oh and by the way good luck
although I admit that I've taken a few
Liberties in this retelling
as things turned out this was not all
that far from the truth
Sam and Elga with whatever charge they
actually received from president
Brewster and despite the challenges
planned pushed prodded cajoled and in
just a few short years took the
institution that Sam once characterized
as quote hopelessly masculine unquote
on a momentous Journey it was a shared
effort but Sam later observed quote
elga's role in transforming Yale cannot
be overstated no single person did more
to assure that co-education went well
than Elga and today's Yale women and men
owe her a great debt of gratitude
for the class of 1973 both women and men
coming to Yale in 1969 was an Act of
Faith no one really knew exactly what we
had or had not signed up for
after the excitement of November's
announcement like so many of my
classmates I scribble an application
meant to convince the powers that be
which turned out to be Sam and Elga
that I could thrive in an institution as
it reinvented itself
however it occurred to me that things
might not go so well
thankfully behind the scenes Elga was
hard at work resolved to make whatever
our class found upon arrival good or
even great
throughout that first year and Beyond it
was deeply comforting to know that Elga
was there working on our behalf
Ally Advocate Champion or as one
classmate put it quote our very own
mother bear unquote with all the
ferocity and devotion that label implies
intent on making the experience of those
early years rich and rewarding
Although our paths must have crossed in
New Haven I remember meeting Elga only
belatedly at a Yale Club luncheon in New
York in 2009. that afternoon Elga told a
story about herself
as you may know in the late 60s the Yale
Club maintained a separate side entrance
for women to avoid them being seen
walking across the lobby
in the car down from New Haven for a
meeting and believing that her male
companions deserved a heads up that
trouble might ensue Elga told them quote
I hope you don't mind but I am not going
into the club through the women's door
unquote and as promised she walked
straight through the front door reserved
for men
she was a woman with absolutely no use
for women's doors or other signifiers of
gender difference
[Music]
[Applause]
Elga accomplished a great deal before
she left Yale in 1972 although not the
full measure of what she knew was needed
while Elga was known as a force to be
reckoned with she did not me this did
not mean that she could surmount every
obstacle or change every mind
certainly problematic gender policies
and practices remained during elga's
time at Yale but it was not for lack of
trying
nonetheless the distanced traveled was
immense Yale had come a very long way
from Brewster's early vision of a
separate coordinate College on the
Divinity School Hill
or his characterization of the plan to
admit women as quote an experiment
unquote to the presence on campus of
hundreds of proud and determined
undergraduate women who with Elga
resolutely and steadfastly behind them
had unequivocally and unapologetically
become real Yale students
and by the close of the decade the
seismic changes of co-education's first
years would seem utterly remote to the
newly arriving students of all genders
somehow Against All Odds the whole
Enterprise succeeded and although Elga
herself could and often did point to the
issues she was later to Able able to say
of the transition I think it went
extremely well unquote
Sam and Elga admitted women they
believed were resilient or as Elga put
it quote sturdy unquote
but Elga herself had more than enough
warmth humor smarts plus dedication
determination and persistence as well as
that signature resilience and frankly
just plain gumption
to more than make up for the rest of us
she once said women students need an
unusual sense of self to persevere in a
predominantly male setting but she could
just as easily have been talking about
herself
I will end then where I began with words
of thanks
exactly 50 years after the class of 1973
graduated we are assembled here at a
proudly robustly co-educational
institution where the typical
undergraduate is barely aware if at all
that Yale was ever a college exclusively
for men
since elga's time generations of
undergraduate women and men have walked
through Phelps gate with each cohort
coming a bit closer to the vision Elga
held for Yale as a modern University
if Elga were here and I'm quite sure she
is looking down on today's celebration
and her former students
we would salute her
congratulations on your extraordinary
work
Kudos on a job beautifully done
but most of all we just want to say
thank you
[Applause]
and I would like to welcome Vera Wells
to the stage
good morning
it's my pleasure to represent the
transfer women who came with you to Yale
in 1969.
as most of us know
the basic plan was to have 500 women
join the one thousand men who were
always assumed to be educated to be the
leaders in society before Yale thought
that women would also join them
and among among those 500 half of you
half of them were to be in your class
and 125 in 71 and 125 and 72.
it turned out that we had more come it
was a higher yield than was expected and
many if not most of the people who
transferred in came from the Seven
Sisters or other other Elite schools
however I was an anomaly
I was a first generation scholarship
student at Howard University and had
almost graduated but had dropped out to
marry a Howard law school graduate and
he brought me to New Haven in September
of 1968.
that's how I wound up at Yale
I never expected to be admitted I never
anticipated being admitted and I doubted
that I would be admitted but my husband
stood over me and insisted that I apply
I then got called in for an interview
with Elgar Wasserman
she was welcoming
she was personable
she showed me to a nice comfortable
chair and then sat beside me
and she had a probing but very warm and
friendly conversation
and when I left her office
I thought that maybe it was a
possibility that I could be at Yale
we ran into each other Crossing campus
from time to time and each time she
would stop and inquire about about how
things were going
and so among the transfer students
I think we each considered Elga to be
our own we all claim Elga as a person
who is pivotal in our lives
in 1973
I was at the Kennedy School at Harvard
and I somehow got contacted and asked
would I be interested in joining a
research project that was going to be
based at the Yale child study center
came as a total surprise to me that I
might have an opportunity to work during
the summer of 1973 back on campus
it was a project being
organized through the Carnegie Council
on children and led by Kenneth kyniston
I wound up being the youngest and least
credentialed person on that working
group that included Marion Wright
Edelman
and Elgar Wasserman
she had been the source
of suggesting
that this person
might contribute something
she made me feel welcomed again
and included and heard and valued
by the end of the summer
she asked to have lunch with me so we
could just discuss what my experience
had been like
and as we concluded our conversation she
asked me what I what I should be doing
for vacation or before I went back to
Harvard where I was a proctor in the
yard and expecting the Freshman to be
coming in soon
when I said I didn't have that in my
budget and had made no plans
she offered me
a week's day at her summer home in South
Wellfleet
and suggested that I invite somebody
else to accompany me since it was a
large house with many
bedrooms
that's when I invited my former teacher
Sylvia Arden Boone to join me
and I think that that was the pivotal
time
when our relationship went from student
and teacher to becoming lifelong best
friends until she died
so I was really overwhelmed and owed
another debt of gratitude for her
influence in my life
in 2007
when I was informed that I would be
getting a Yale medal
I had an opportunity to reflect on my
experience at Yale how I got here
and how I felt
committed to being involved in a broader
level
and so I sought out Elgar Wasserman
to thank her
and I had the pleasure of inviting her
and Harry to join me as my guest at the
metal dinner
two years after that
I reached out to Elga again
because my classmates had been tired of
going to the Yale club for another
classmates untimely memorial service
we felt that some of us were dying too
soon
and so we wanted to do something that
would be fun and uplifting and so we
came up with the idea of celebrating 40
Years of co-education at the Yale Club
over lunch
and so
I invited Elga
or
dean of students
John Wilkinson and Sam whom I had not
known until that time
and so
many of you joined us because we opened
up that 1971 event
to also include women from 72 and 73.
and we realized how many people we did
not know
when we were on campus
and it turned out that Sam and Elga and
John had not been together for over 20
years
and that event was actually the only
time
that the three of them were on a panel
to discuss their experiences with
co-education
although we had been chastised and said
why don't you wait until the 50th
our classmates felt
we didn't know if we would be here for
the 50th
and so
I'm just so honored and thrilled that
she showed up
then Along With Sam and John to help
encourage us Inspire us and give us the
real skinny on how we got here
and what it took to make yield go co-ed
Yale was not a perfect experience for
many of us
but
when you think that they made it happen
in less than 10 months
they only made the decision to go co-ed
in November
and they admitted Us in April and we
were here in September
and so it is a pleasure to be here with
all of you
some that whom I met for the first time
in 2019 when we celebrated being first
women
and thank you for the class of 1973
including us in welcoming us as we
celebrate this unveiling thank you very
much
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you Vera and thanks to all of our
speakers uh for really uh quite moving
remarks we have come almost to the
moment you've all been waiting for and
right before we get there I just want to
point out a few University leaders who
are with us today
vice president for alumni Affairs and
development John O'Neill is here today
Pericles Lewis the dean of Yale College
is up front
[Applause]
Lynn Cooley the dean of The Graduate
School of Arts and Sciences is here as
well
it might be others but that's who I can
see
and I mentioned them
because elga's Legacy has had an
influence on all of us as administrators
do you know it's the Deans who are the
academic leaders of this University
and 60 percent of them six zero sixty
percent of them are women today and uh
[Music]
[Applause]
that wasn't the case just a decade ago
okay
and now I'm delighted to ask
Brenda zlamani the acclaimed artist who
painted this portrait
to come up and she will unveil it and I
will help her
okay yes
there it is
[Music]
[Applause]
I haven't seen it in a while so I'm
getting reacquainted but I'm hello
everyone
um thank you for coming
um first of all I would like to thank
Peter salovey for inviting me to take
part in this significant work and
everyone who contributed to elga's
Portrait including Susan Gibbons who
advised me on numerous topics in San
Chauncey who helped bring Elga to Life
by sharing his wonderful memories of her
with me it's exciting to be part of a
project and a movement to diversify
iconography in public spaces
painting of Elgar Wasserman my third
portrait at Yale is in many ways my most
personal project as a 14 year old
emancipated minor in New Haven in the
1970s I had the privilege of of taking
classes at Yale's College before college
program and of studying with many
idealistic and talented Yale students
who taught at the newly formed High
School in the community and at
Educational Center for the Arts without
these programs I probably would not have
gone to college and these experiences
that altered the course of my life
wouldn't have been possible without
Elgar Wasserman
although I arrived in New Haven in 1974
a few years after the first women were
accepted to Yale as many of you will
remember it was still a transitional
time for women on campus and it was a
period of great excitement and change
for society in general and for me
personally so in painting Elgar
Wasserman I hope to create a portrait
that was true to her likeness but also
spoke about that pivotal time
here are the few steps here are a few of
the steps involved in making this
painting all of my portraits begin with
research and after carefully reviewing
numerous photos of Elga I selected two
characteristic photos of her seated
behind a desk as the starting point for
my sketch for inspiration I looked at
historical paintings of single figures
at the desk including portraits by
Holbein Vermeer Rembrandt Degas and
Cezanne I love the intense psychology
and direct gaze and Rembrandt's
portraits and holbein's use of color
grounds as well as the zigzagging books
that create a pyramid with the subject
at the top in paintings like Degas
portrait of Durante so I invented a pose
of Elga that combines these historical
Inspirations and also references a
well-known photo of her at the desk
holding both her glasses and a pencil in
one hand and you could see this hand
over here I actually
borrowed that directly from the photo so
that is elga's hand the other hand is
mine
um
um next I had to decide what to put on
her desk and I discussed various objects
with Sam including a map of Campus or a
relevant issue of Yale Daily News but I
finally chose a selection of key
feminist volumes from the period it was
a pleasure to revisit so many familiar
Staples and with elga's daughter Diana's
help I was even able to check which
books were in elga's collection
beautifully designed book covers helped
tell an important story of the time and
I appreciate the enigmatic use of
rancusi's sculpture the kiss on sex and
the Yale student a booklet given to all
Yale students that I remember well
and by including the black woman edited
by Tony Cade I had the chance of
incorporating a second portrait into the
painting but actually it's a third
because I've hidden my customary
self-portrait in elga's glasses you can
sort of see me peeking out so there were
three people in this painting
when I think back to the Early to the
late 60s and the early 70s I see
electric orange yellow pink and
chartreuse so from the start I knew the
painting would be bright and I chose a
vivid cadmium orange for the ground of
the color
of the background during my research I
noticed that Elga favored patterns and
after scrolling through dozens of
vintage blouses online I finally
purchased the perfect Emilio Pucci for
her to wear I think she would have liked
that shirt
um
it was an honor a privilege and a great
pleasure to have been entrusted with the
legacy of Elgar Wasserman and to revisit
this exciting time I hope the book
covers that I recreated in the painting
Inspire the viewer on their own journey
of discovery about the women's movement
at Yale and Beyond the college
that the vibrant colors and patterns
transport them to this crucial era and
that the realism of the portrait
introduces them to a remarkable woman
whose impact is still being felt today
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
well thank you Brenda for the talk but
especially for a portrait that is
simultaneously playful and serious
political and honors such an important
figure in Yale's history thank you for
capturing all of that and so much more
and I grew up in a mid-century middle
class home and
all my mother's Furniture was the color
of the background
of this portrait
again I want to thank all of our
speakers I want to thank our artists I
want to thank all of you I want to thank
those of you online
for joining us on at this historic
ceremony on this historic and wonderful
day thank you so much and we will
endeavor to honor
elga's memory and her mission in
everything we do going forward here at
Yale University thank you for coming
[Music]